Olá meus amigos minhas amigas para mais
uma live eu tenho aqui hoje uma
convidada muito especial D eliset cfia
que é uma excelente médica que vê a
saúde como um todo mas usa os recursos
da dermatologia da tricologia como
grande armas para ver a saúde geral
Então nós vamos começar agora também
transmitir no Instagram estamos
transmitindo ao vivo agora no YouTube e
no Instagram você que está acompanhando
no Instagram nós estamos hoje
entrevistando uma excelente médica uma
das melhores do Brasil uma médica
dermatologista tricologista mas que vê a
sua saúde como todo usando os recursos o
que o cabelo conta sobre você para que
você possa ter assim um bom diagnóstico
e as pistas que Ela utiliza utilizando
essa visão do cabelo e da pele ela
consegue então direcionar o seu
tratamento então Eh Muito obrigado pela
endido a nossa solicitação ter recebido
nosso convite ter aceitado Boa noite D
Elisete excelente noite a todos sou
muito contente muito animada aí de poder
compartilhar conhecimentos com um colega
da área da integrativa também né além
porque a gente vê hoje os pacientes
sendo esquartejados né vendo cada órgão
do corpo de uma maneira não sistêmica
então poder conversar e ter parceiros
que compactuam né da mesma filosofia is
só maravilhoso né maravilha Muito bacana
ter você também aqui uma médica tão
conceituada também nessa área de
dermatologia e também da Medicina
integrativa bem vamos começar a nossa
conversa com o Dr Elizete eh pedindo
para ela como é que ela poderia nos
explicar como que as alergias podem
influenciar a saúde do cabelo e levar a
queda Quais são os mecanismos que estão
envolvidos nesse processo
é interessante Alé porque eh muito de
buscar essa área foi através da minha
saúde Então eu fui uma criança muito
alérgica muito doente tive alergias de
pele alergias respiratórias e convulsões
até aos 4 anos de idade e foi Através
disso que eu fui fazer medicina para
descobrir o que eu tinha então a minha
busca no no nesse diagnóstico de causas
de alergia mais 30 anos e quando eu
cheguei na na área da Medicina eu fui
procurar dentro das várias
especialidades todas as que estavam
relacionadas a causas alérgicas Então
muitos quadros neurocomportamentais
podem ser sintomas de alergia então no
final de 32 anos de estudos eu descobri
que o problema das minhas alergias das
minhas convulsões da queda de cabelo que
eu tinha era arroz e água a o cloro da
água então o que que acontece ele são
substâncias que funcionam que eu falo
igual o sapo na panela né Você joga o
sapo na panela de água quente ele
percebe que a toxina né que tá quente
ele pula fora agora uma microtox algo
que é pouquinho todo dia igual você
jogar o sapo numa panela de água fria e
esquentando devagarzinho as toxinas elas
vão se acumulando progressivamente o
corpo vai se acostumando com aquela as
cargas tóxicas e vai liberando
substâncias que são os nossos os nossos
soldadinhos de defesa Então a gente tem
uma cascata como se fosse pelotões o
primeiro pelotão são mediadores
inflamatórios então a pessoa tem o que
aites dermatite rinite sinusite Iti Iti
por liberação de marcadores
inflamatórios inespecíficos para tentar
combater essas essas toxinas
se a pessoa continua vivendo num
ambiente estressor tendo contato com às
vezes uma coisa que é saudável mas para
ela faz mal o corpo começa a liberar
antígeno anticorpo que são as
imunoglobulinas e podem surgir doenças
autoimunes eu cheguei a ter cinco
doenças autoimunes Olá Aí cheguei a ter
tirite de rimoto lupus doença Mista do
colágeno e diabetes com 32 an já tinha
cinco autoimunes todas relacionadas ao
meu quadro de alergia e a gente acaba
tratando esses pacientes com quê com
imunossupressor e antialérgico e não
trata não detecta o ambiente e aí depois
disso começam as infecções Então os leuc
costos os nossos glóbulos brancos eles
são também soldadinhos de defesa para
tentar combater essas toxinas ambientais
e a pessoa começa a ter infecções de
repetição né as otites as as amidal ites
as infecções Aí chega uma hora que o
corpo não sabe mais o que fazer ele
começa a utilizar os hormônios para
combater essas toxinas então começa a
usar insulina começa a usar cortisol
começa a usar primeiros os menos vitais
depois os mais vitais então ele começa
converter a testosterona a progesterona
o estradiol que são hormônios menos
vitais para hormônios mais vitais para
cortisol adrenalina e usa umas enzimas
de guerra Aroma a calpa redutase que
transforma esses hormônios em algumas
substâncias que causam o afinamento do
cabelo a calvice né alopécia padrão
ondog genética aumento da próstata
gordura no fígado acne oleosidade queda
de cabelo cansaço fadiga eh aumento de
celulite lipedema Mas isso é
consequência de um ambiente estressor
então quando quando a gente vai analisar
o cabelo a pele ele é o órgão que tá de
interface entre o mundo exterior e o
nosso mundo interior então ele é o
primeiro soldado de defesa aí que vai
combater essas exotoxinas ambientais
então a gente utilizar o cabelo para
detectar essas toxinas ambientais a
gente consegue analisar 8 a 20 anos
antes de aparecer no exame de sangue
Olha que bacana então é realmente algo
bem
preventivo interessante tem uma pergunta
aqui que eu acho que cabe nesse momento
você acha interessante a gente alternar
as suas explicações com respondendo à
dúvidas Ou você prefere falar primeiro
tudo e depois responder vamos já
responder que aí entra na linha de
raciocínio acho que legal é essa
pergunta acho que tem a ver com o que
você falou aí existe essa correlação que
ele tá perguntando entre partes do
cabelo com órgãos diferentes ou não é
isso aí Elise o que que acontece quando
a gente é formado como peto tem a
embriologia né organogênese e para cada
pedaço da nossa pele a gente chama de
dermátomo tem um metâmero que é o nervo
artéria e o vaso que tem a mesma origem
embriológica e o mesmo órgão Então são
os dermátomos os metâmeros e os órgãos
que TM a mesma origem a gente se a gente
for dividir o nosso corpo a gente divide
tem três blocos né o ectoderme mesoderme
e endoderme eles vê de todos
praticamente do espermatozoide do óvulo
vira ovo igoto né aí Divide dois 4 oito
mórula blastula glasa tronco embrionário
e três folhetos esses três folhetos é
como que fossem Três Rios a ectoderma
mesoderma endoderma da ectoderma a gente
vai formar pele cabelo olho né a a o
esmalte todas as mucosas e a primeira
camada da pele e a aste do cabelo o
segundo a mesoderma eu vou formar a
segunda camada da Pele que é a Derme eu
vou formar também a parte do
osteoarticular cardiovascular Genito
urinário e a parte da glândula Sebá do
fio de cabelo e do endoderma eu vou
formar o a a o bulbo capilar vou formar
toda a parte do pulmão do fígado do
pâncreas do intestino então a os nossos
dentes o nosso cabelo a nossa pele são
reservas metabólicas quando a gente tá
com a saúde boa a gente tem uma reserva
de hormônios vitaminas e minerais nesses
órgãos quando a gente começa a baixar
nossos níveis de hormônios vitaminas
minerais a gente vende o almoço para
pagar a janta por isso que antigamente a
lain falava o quê vamos que você compra
um cavalo olhando os dentes né da
reserva metabólica como como que se
comprava um escravo olhando os dentes a
na na Bíblia já fala que as áreas de
pelada eram usadas para identificar
lepra por isso que falava de cortar o
mal pela raiz se raspava o cabelo para
diminuir a quantidade de bacilos para
diminuir a contaminação pela letra e aí
de acordo com a área do do couro nós
temos os órgãos correlacionados então
aqui a tireoide um pouquinho mais para
baixo pâncreas região da nuca
adrenais essa região aqui tá relacionada
a fígado intestino a região aqui de cima
coronal pineal e a linha média eixo
hormonal masculino e feminino Então tudo
isso tá relacionado à embriologia
organogênese é muito legal você vê que a
gente estudou isso na faculdade mas é
aplicabilidade prática na clínica diária
que a gente traz isso de volta é muito
bacana tricologia integrativa bem
interessante Então complementando o
raciocínio aqui ele pergunta se você
pode prever com 10 anos de antecedência
as doenças que que acontece além dentro
da homotoxicologia alemã Eles já estudam
isso há mais de 7.000 anos né então eles
estudam o papel das toxinas no processo
de adoecimento Então são seis fases do
adoecimento uma fase que é uma fase de
excreção Aonde a célula vai tentar jogar
essas toxinas mais para para fora porque
tá entrando mais toxina do Que vitamina
então o corpo tem que trabalhar para
mais então geralmente o corpo fica
cansado a queixa do paciente é só
cansaço só fadiga depois a fase dois que
é a fase
inflamatória depois VM a fase três de de
deposição onde começa a ter mais toxina
no intracelular do que fora da célula e
essas três primeiras fases eles chamam
de fases humoris que são fases que são
só filminho é só o funcionamento da
célula tentando combater as toxinas
ambientais se você for fazer um exame de
sangue uma biópsia tentar dosar você não
consegue porque você não tem uma
deposição de toxinas que você consegue
palpar a nível de exame de sangue de
exames laboratoriais de exames de imagem
aí depois vem a fase quatro que é a fase
de impregnação onde você já tem as
toxinas depositadas no intracelular aí
que começa a aparecer alterações nos
exames convencionais depois a fase de
degeneração que a célula faz o quê ela
tenta aumentar a superfície de absorção
para tentar melhorar as trocas sair mais
as toxinas entrar vitaminas depois as
fase de desdiferenciação que aí a célula
já tá totalmente alterada então esse
período de seis fases entre uma fase e
outra em torno de de 2 a 3 anos por isso
a gente fala de de 8 a 20 anos antes
então não é que a gente consegue prever
mas a gente vê se o paciente tá vivendo
num ambiente que é geneticamente
compatível ou seja ele tem mais
nutrientes do que toxinas ele vai ficar
mais saudável igual pegar uma samambaia
e Plantar lá na floresta amazônica lá
vai viver saudável se eu pego a mesma
samamba e levo ela lá para camp Jordão
né que é frio ela vai tá num ambiente
inóspito para ela então o o processo de
estress oxidativo de degeneração vai ser
maior é a taxa de enferrujamento maior é
a coisa certa a pessoa certa no ambiente
errado né então é mais ou menos
Inclusive a tabela que você tá falando
tem aqui no custor não sei se vai dar
para mostrar pro pessoal mas vou tentar
ó dá dando para ver aí a tabela aqui ó
Aquela ler é isso exatamente aqui né A
tabela da homotoxicologia É isso aí ó
dentro dativa né lain a gente tem que
ter isso tempo todo né tem que tá lá
pregado na parede não é verdade é para
ajudar a lembrar né É verdade e aíe tá
perguntando também se a o cabelo branco
tem a ver com
desnutrição nem sempre né a nós temos
três fases do crescimento capilar a
gente tem uma fase chamada anágena que é
a fase que o cabelo cresce Depois tem
uma fase de de repouso que a catágena e
depois uma fase que o cabelo cai aí já
nasce um outro fiozinho né o cabelo tem
esse ciclo nasce cresce cai e já nasce
outro no mesmo ósteo o a pigmentação do
cabelo ele ocorre no final da fase aná
então primeiro o cabelo nasce depois ele
é pigmentado e essa pigmentação ela vai
depender da taça de oxigenação bubar
quanto mais oxigenado o nosso bubo maior
o fornecimento de nutrientes vitaminas e
minerais mas tijolo eu mando pro pro
nosso pedreiro para fazer o material de
construção então o cabelo consegue ser
estruturado e pigmentado lembrar que
todo o processo de pigmentação ele vai
depender da pineal do hormônio
melanotrófico do fígado né porque todo
aquela ação da tirosinase para
transformar tirosina em melanina vai
depender do fígado e de você ter ti in
de você comer gema de ovo comer os
alimentos cicos de tirozina Então nem
sempre é só carência de nutriente pode
ser por exemplo uma alteração no fígado
parasitas metais toxinas uma fadiga de
pinu a pessoa não tá dormindo direito ou
hoje ela em e poluição eletromagnética
radiação é uma das principais causas de
cabelo branco por quê Porque a poluição
eletromagnética radiação que é wi-fi
internet celular Cia é bronc constritor
por vaso constritor então ele é uma das
principais causas Como que eu faço o
diagnóstico de uma paciente
hipersensível
isso Ó a alopécia androgenética a gente
fala de dois duas fases da da Medicina
nós somos al jovens né fase pré genômica
a gente se formou antes da década né da
antes de 2013 então a gente aprendeu né
que tudo era genético e não tinha cura a
gente herdava 300 milhões de gens o G da
calvice da Hipertensão do diabetes do
Câncer independente do que a gente a
gente fizesse na vida a gente ia
manifestar esse gen e o mínimo que a
gente tinha que fazer o quê tomar
remédio pro resto da vida né E aí mesmo
assim a gente at essas doenças Projeto
Genoma em 2003 mostrou que a gente só
tem 20.000 gentes e que
98% do nosso Genoma Responde ao ambiente
que a gente vive é como se fosse uma
planta um projeto de uma casa e o
material de construção que a gente
entrega para esse projeto vai fazer com
que a gente expresse gens da saúde ou
gens da doença expressão gênica que é o
Bruce lipton o pai da epigenética Então
essa coisa de alopecia androgenética
genético não tem cura eu vou usar um
óleo de semente de abóbora um bloqueador
de aromatase um bloqueador de cinco
redat para dar um calab boca no gente
isso aí é antes de 2003 não se bloqueia
uma enzima né Tem uma frase da nós da
integrativa que é assim toda vez que
você você muda uma fisiologia você cria
uma patologia né a fisiologia muito
linda Se você bloquear uma fisiologia
você cria uma patologia você tem que
entender qual desses 2500 fatores
epigenéticos estão acordando os seus
gens da doença e adormecendo os da saúde
não é com óleo de semente Deó que você
vai resolver esse problema não tem que
olhar mais a fundo né com certeza
né outra pergunta aqui do Eliseu como é
que po pode fazer para engrossar
naturalmente o cabelo ou fortalecer o
cabelo Então olha só que legal o cabelo
ele é um marcador de ambientação então
se você tá no ar que é compatível com
você você tá num fazendo uma alimentação
que é compatível com você você tá tendo
um estilo de vida que é compatível com
você pensa lá em que essa região mais
inútil do nosso corpo é a periferia né
ponta do dedo ponta do nariz ponta dos
pés e couro cabeludo todas as vezes que
você tá passando por uma situação neuro
estressora neur estressora não é só
psicossomática mas o ar a água poluente
o ambiente que não é compatível com a
sua necessidade o seu corpo vai fazer o
quê a gente vende vender o almoço para
pagar a janta ele vai vaso constringir
aonde é menos Vital então tipo da
cintura para baixo não é vital braços
pernas não é Vital e coro cabelo tudo
não é vital para mander vitaminas
nutrientes minerais onde é mais Vital
então da pineal até a adrenal Então se
tá o cabelo tá fino significa você tá
fazendo alguma coisa que o seu corpo não
tá gostando que eu gosto de fazer é um
teste uma dica legal para vocês tudo que
você for fazer você faz um teste da
ponta do nariz e das pontas dos dedos
antes e depois ah eu vou beber um copo
d'água vou saber se essa água faz bem
para mim se essa água se essa substância
for algo que for ressonante para você
Você vai ficar igual ou vai ficar mais
quente porque vai te fornecer ATP calor
caloria se for uma coisa que faz mal pra
sua saúde você vai ter o quê uma
vasoconstrição periférica a ponta do
nariz e a ponta dos dedos vão ficar
geladas então quero saber se eu tenho
uma alergia uma intolerância alimentar e
não tenho dor de barriga come o alimento
e vê como que ficou a sua temperatura da
ponta do do nariz e dos dedos depois que
a gente come a gente tem que ficar
quente tem que ter calor eu vou
abastecer meu corpo para ter energia se
eu abasteço o meu corpo e eu fico com
mais sono mais sonolência mais preguiça
mais frio eu tô dando um desalento eu tô
dando colocando o melhor óleo diesel às
vezes não carro a gasolina e não vai dar
certo
perfeito ele tá perguntando se consegue
reverter o cabelo branco com suplemento
99% dos casos hoje de cabelos brancos tá
relacionado à contaminação por metais
tóxicos tá infelizmente além nós estamos
respirando hoje 35 bilhões de poluentes
ambientais lançados na atmosfera ano
então é e é petróleo é pesticida
agrotóxico microplástico Se as pessoas
não entenderem hoje né a gente que
estuda homotoxicologia há uns anos né
sabe que não dá pra gente ficar
utilizando fígado rins intestino para
fazer detox fígado rins intestino pulmão
foi criado para eliminar toxinas da
fisiologia se você quiser manter o seu
terreno biológico Limpo você tem que
avaliar como que tá o ar a água que você
e fazer o quê destoxificação por escalda
pés por banhos de inversão tem uma
rotina igual os europeus fazem lá há
7000 anos né de manter o terreno
biológico limpo e por quê porque cada
molécula de toxina ele funciona como
disruptor é o chiclete no buraco da
fechadura que entope a absorção em em
média tá na minha média pelos testes que
eu faço nos meus pacientes entre 100 a
150 moléculas de hormônios vitaminas e
minerais por exemplo eu não posso comer
arroz então se eu como um prato de arroz
eu teria que comer sem 150 pratos de
hormônios vitaminas e minerais para
neutralizar o prato de arroz que eu comi
é impossível então enquanto eu não
detectar o que tá consumindo combatendo
quando as minhas vitaminas meus
hormônios minerais o suplemento vai ser
usado para limpar o chão infelizmente é
o que a gente mais pega hoje na
atualidade perfeito
eh tem mais uma pergunta dele aqui
indicação de de Shampoo
natural que não temha química adoro
fazer os meus próprios shampoos eu tenho
uma receitinha que a gente usa o shampoo
de mandioca né que é muito interessante
Então você utiliza o próprio óleo de
coco né Você mistura com a com a
mandioca depois eu posso colocar aí no
no seu canal depois essa essa essa
receitinha é bem interessante Então
sempre pensar assim que um shampoo ele
quanto mais é translúcido por isso que a
gente fala que shampoo neutro el tem que
ser translúcido menos alumínio ele vai
ter né e o papel dele é Abrir cutícula
para sair a carga tóxica e depois você
condicionar fechar o fio para equilibrar
o PH que pode ser com óleo de coco pode
ser com óleo de alguma semente natural
então é um processo de equilíbrio ácido
básico então uma da um dos Testes que eu
ensino fazer é o oring test é o bidor
então a pessoa segurar o frasco do
shampoo com a mão fraca e fazer o oing
teste com a mão forte como que funciona
isso da ponta do dedo até a ponta do
outro dedo eu tenho uma impedância
elétrica de - 60 MW que é o que a gente
tem de impedância elétrica crânio cdal
60 vezes 10 vezes por minuto se eu
seguro um shampoo na palma da minha mão
ele tem que ser orgânico nosso corpo é
orgânico se eu bater um ser humano no
liquidificador ele tem que ter o quê
carbono nitrogênio hidrogênio água sais
minerais e proteínas só pode ter
alumínio não cádmio enxofre arsênico
Cobalto chumbo Mercúrio não então o
nosso corpo não pode ter metal Então se
o essa substância esse shampoo é
orgânico só tem realmente água sais
minerais substâncias naturais ela ele é
condut ele vai não vai atrapalhar minha
condutibilidade elétrica e eu consigo
manter o tonos muscular aí a outra
pessoa vem cá vem me ajudar aí a outra
pessoa vai lá vai fazer a força né com
os dois dedinhos ó Vi vai fazer a força
eu vou segurar uma uma uma coisa que sei
lá vou segurar meu chá Meu chazinho aqui
segura o chá ela vai fazer a força ó eu
fico forte tá aí se eu for segurar por
exemplo meu celular que tem radiação ó
aí ela vai fazer a força ó ó eu perco a
força por quê Porque é uma coisa
metálica que vai funcionar igual uma
resistência de choveiro que vai puxar
elétrons e eu vou perder meu tônus
muscular Então existe Associação Médica
brasileiro O Ring test o bidor que forma
os médicos né 18 meses para fazer isso
mas é um teste de sinesi olia
kinesiologia que ajuda a gente
identificar nos cosméticos se eles são S
realmente orgânicos naturais você eles
têm metais pesticidas agrotóxicos a
gente é é bem legal vocês ficarem
brincando disso a gente ensina todos os
pacientes né é interessante até você
tocar no assunto da kinesiologia que
semana que vem nós vamos conversar com o
Professor Fausto Bosque né ah que é que
é um estudioso disso daí né então Ó
gente não perca a Live né semana que vem
quinta-feira que vem quinta-feira que
vem
bem vamos voltar pro assunto original
depois a gente responde mais algumas
perguntas né você tava falando sobre a
relação entre as alergias e o cabelo a
minha segunda pergunta é quais são os
sinais e sintomas específicos que os
pacientes devem observar que podem
indicar que a queda de cabelo está
relacionada à Alergia ou alguma
intolerância são cinco principais
sintomas então sempre o paciente vai
comparar ele com ele mesmo por exemplo
eu não posso comparar eu com uma outra
pessoa que geneticamente tem um cabelo
desse tamanho eu tenho que comparar
sempre eu comigo mesmo então eu sei
quanto que eu tô quando eu tô bem Como
que eu tô então primeira coisa espessura
da fibra capilar Você tem que sempre
fazer esse teste né de ver a espessura
da fibra capilar quando você tá em
contato com alguma toxina aí é como se o
nosso cabelo você já comprou aqueles
vasinhos de de de entro hortelã que
vende lá no supermercado né Aí você
compra e não coloca água não fica assim
né a mesma coisa que acontece no nosso
cabelo quando ele tá submetido a uma
exotoxina a uma a um fator alérgico é
como se desidratar toda a água da aste
capilar ele murcha ele fica fininho de
um dia pro outro de um dia pro outro é
aquele vasinho de planta que você
esqueceu de porar ele faz assim ó aí fal
esqueci de pôr e ele às vezes ele vai lá
e renova de novo então a espessura da
aste capilar é um dos fatores fala nossa
meu cabelo tá minguado né então isso é é
um dos fatores que você vai pensar
segundo fator coisa de dia a dia tá
segundo fator é eletricidade estática é
o fato de você passar a mão na aste
capilar aqui ó e o dedo correr cada um
tem o seu cada vez cab cabelo mais liso
passa de um gito mas você vê como que o
seu corpo se comporta você sabe mais ou
menos quando você passa que o cabelo não
fica embaraçado quando você tem contato
com toxinas ambientais com alguma
substância que é
alergênica você fica com stress
oxidativo você libera radicais livres e
os radicais livres geram na ache capilar
eletricidade estática você fica lá da
choque na porta do carro o cabelo fica
arrepiado fica cheio de fris Então se
você acordou com seu cabelo arrepiado
cheio de friz dando choque na porta do
carro pode ser que no dia anterior você
teve alguma contaminação ambiental tá
terceira coisa couro cabeludo couro
cabeludo ele vai identificar o seu
intestino ó tá lendo couro cabelo do
paciente você está vendo o intestino
dele então começou a dar caspa coceira
seborreia vermelhidão significa que você
pode ter se contaminado aí com algum
parasita ou Você pode ter comido algum
alimento contaminado alguma coisa assim
a gente fala persistindo os sintomas né
o médico deverá ser consultado não
adianta ficar passendo shampoo ante
seborreia 100% dos casos que eu atendo a
não ser que a minha estatística esteja
furada né Ela é em 15.000 pacientes né
mas 100% deles paciente com seborreia
até que prove ao contrário é parasita é
parasita intestinal então seborreia
psoríase né cebria
é sinal de parasita tá tem gente que tá
gastando quilos e quilos de shampoo
antioleosidade e a pessoa tá com
parasita tá bebendo água contaminada tá
comendo alimentos contaminados de mau
preparo tá outra coisa é a modificação
da
coloração então às vezes não sei se já
você já viu a pessoa entra na piscina o
cabelo fica verde né ou o paciente
começa a reclamar que vai no
cabeleireiro começa a pigmentar o cabelo
e o cabelo ficou alaranjado avermelhado
ou seja o mesmo procedimento que ele
fazia mudou de cor o que que faz o
cabelo mudar de cor contaminação por
metais Então se o seu cabelo ficar verde
quando você entra na piscina Você pode
ter uma predisposição genética a
contaminação por Cloro como que você faz
para neutralizar cabelo verde vinagre de
maçã você pega lá o borrifador metade
vin de maçã medade de água filtrada e
borrifa Mas você tem que tomar cuidado
com cloro seu cabelo tá ficando mais
avermelhado Você pode ter uma
predisposição a contaminação por
arsênico casca fibra bagaço casca de
fruta casca de grão verduras cruas
excesso de lectinas então começa a
deixar uma coloração mais avermelhada no
seu tô ficando Ruivo Pode ser que você
tá tendo uma contaminação por arsênico e
o cabelo ele começou a ficar mais verde
né uma coloração mais verde mais vinho
uma coisa assim pode ser contaminação
por chumbo Mercúrio então tudo que é
vermelho avermelhado né então Eh
corantes conservantes acidulantes são
que a gente mais vê né que a pessoa vai
ficando meio roxa meio avermelhada pode
ser por contaminação né então esses são
os principais cinturas sintomas e a
elasticidade da aste Cap pelar o cabelo
começa a ficar quebradiço quebra a
quebra elasticidade daqui é o quinto
sintoma elasticidade tá relacionado ao
grau de hidratação né você que é
nefrolog urologista né pra parte
uroginecológica a gente sabe que o nosso
corpo é todo fofoqueiro a água que tá na
pão da cabeça tá na ponta do pé então
não adianta você quer aa fazer uma
hidratação na minha fibra capilar você
tá todo deshidratado você tá
deshidratado seu CBO seu coração seu
pulmão seu ris se fenal não adianta
então às vezes você tá bebendo uma água
contaminada ou não tá bebo uma
quantidade suficiente de água ou você tá
não tá bebendo coloides água com sais
minerais tem que avaliar você como um
todo não adianta só ficar passando
creminho no cabelo que não vai adiantar
nada perfeito excelente
ã então existem tipos específicos de
alergias que são mais propensas a causar
queda de cabelo e como é que elas se
diferenciam das outras em termos de
impacto no couro cabeludo e nos fios
então Alé olha só que interessante
interessante né E você pode segmentar
por dermátomos e metâmeros né então por
exemplo normalmente aqui quando a pessoa
começa a ter problema aqui atrás ó né de
crescimento aqui ou falhas nessa região
tá relacionado com as adrenais com
toxinas com alergenos que sobrecarregam
mais as adrenais as suprarrenais n Então
a gente tem aí muita coisa hoje relacion
tô falando da minha estatística tá muita
coisa relacionada a toxinas
lipossolúveis
chumbo Mercúrio cárdio poluentes
ambientais fumaça entendeu corantes
coisas lipossolúveis que as adrenais
coitadinhas elas não conseguem não dar
conta então normalmente são as toxinas
lipossolúveis e relacionado Quais são os
principais parasitas que o paciente tem
que acomete as glândulas suprarrenais
você deve atender de mono Clamídia né
Clamídia que que é uma DST aí que as
pessoas às vezes nem sabem que tem
Clamídia principal causa de
infertilidade masculina feminina hoje a
gente sabe que é clamídia né E são as
viroses subclínicas e toxoplasmose né
que é um cocozinho de gato contamina o
ambiente por 180 dias às vezes a pessoa
é portadora crônica sintomática de
Toxoplasma e nem tá sabendo né Essa
região do pâncreas aqui ela tá muito
relacionada que tem essa região mediana
nem é o Curuca aqui aqui no meio da da
nuca ela tá relacionada a contaminação
por metais tóxicos normalmente eh
alumínio Platina níquel tá então ela tá
relacionada Se eu jogar um balde de
metal no corpo Qual que é o órgão que
mais tem tropismo por metais tops os
pâncreas a gente vê muita gente
pré-diabética que acha que é diabética
resistência insulínica só que o o metal
ele tá entupindo os receptores né as
células Beta do pantas e não tá deixando
ter essa leitura né da insulina com a
com aquela glicose e vice-versa então
Essa região é muito sugestiva de metais
tóxicos aqui relacionado a tireoide a
gente vê muitas
viroses vias aéreas superiores aqui né a
pessoa Às vezes tem herps vírus
citomegalovírus herpst temar vírus né
vírus da rubéola incubados e a focos
dentais Nico né necrose infra cavitação
canais dentais tratados há mais de 5
anos sem isolamento sem microscopia como
depositórios virais gerando aí essa
vasoconstrição principalmente aqui na
região da tireoide e gerando aquela
calvice né do Papa aqui né da da região
coronal aqui em cima né essa parte aqui
de cima que é a área da pineal da Fadiga
de pineal tá mais relacionado às
alergias
respiratórias pessoas que têm alergia
cloro e fluor da água então pessoa que
às vezes nem sabe que tem problema com
cloro problema do cloro Flu excesso né
então é muito inalatório pessoa tem
problema de depressão ansiedade não
dorme direito começa a ter rarefação
capilar difusa fica tratando como
ansiedade depressão e às vezes a maneira
toxicidade pelo cloro e fluor E aqui
nessa região aqui a gente tem o que a
gente chama de alopécia fibrosante
frontal que quando eu fiz faculdade foi
junto com você lá né A gente nem vai
falar para achar que a gente é é jovem
né mas quase 30 anos atrás né que que
acontece não tinha isso não tinha
alopécia fibrosante de fron eu lembro na
época da faculdade que me chamaram falar
rápido rápido vem ver que nunca mais
você vai ver na vida hoje você Vado
esquina Então tá muito relacionado a
cosméticos somente esses cosméticos
toque seco ninguém pode suar mais né Tem
tudoo lindo maravilhoso cheio de
alumínio né Platina ncoo cosméticos
perolados que puxam o quê poluição
eletromagnética e radiação Então passou
muito cosmético tá muito tempo contato
com os poluentes com wi-fi internet
celular 5g e tem focos subclínicos
odontológicos as a população brasileira
que menos trata os dentes né
periodontite endodonti tudo isso gera
vaso constrição aqui e gera rarefação
frontal cada vez a linha média da
população tá ficando mais para trás aí
Por conta desses cosméticos né que hoje
estão são cheios de eh eh xenobióticos
cheios de disruptores né E cheno
estrógeno a deve pegar bastante gente
com problema uroginecológica urológico
às vezes por disruptores né coisa que
compete com
hormônio sim sim é
verdade então existe uma maneira de
diferenciar entre queda de cabelo
causada por alergias ou queda de cabelo
por outras
condições olha Laí vou ser bem sincera
hoje né foi a evolução do homem do mundo
moderno tá eu posso dividir a minha a
minha atuação acadêmica Nos primeiros 15
anos e nos segundos 15 anos tá nos
primeiros 15 anos a gente tinha
problemas tiroidianos subclínicos a
gente tinha anemia ferropriva a gente
tinha doenças carenciais né Depois que
1980 90 chegou aquela le isolação temos
que enriquecer todos os alimentos com
ferro vitamina sais minerais não é
verdade pouca carência nutricional
grande problema de 15 20 anos para cá é
aumento desses contaminantes desses
poluentes pesticidas agrotóxicos Chen
nóos conservante corante acidulante
então assim praticamente 100% dos
pacientes entes hoje a queda de cabelo
tem um componente alérgico eu posso tô
falando a não ser que a minha
estatística desses últimos 15 20 anos
seja falha 15.000 pacientes viciados
entende mas hoje não chega nenhum
paciente aqui que não tem né algum
contaminante exógeno é só uma um fator
nutricional só um fator hormonal
praticamente faz quase 20 anos que eu
não pego assim sempre tem um componente
algico relacionado a isso perfeito Tem
uma pergunta ão relacionada aqui Qual a
relação entre as alergias e a saúde
intestinal nem sempre um paciente com
alergia
alimentar tem sintoma intestinal eu ten
um artigo C posso te mandar para você
postar que legal existe um artigo
falando que existe três tipos de sín de
má absorção intestinal aquela clássica
que a gente tem a pessoa com dor de
barriga alteração de abomina de Ferro
anticorpos aquela coisa clássica que
você vai fazer uma endoscopia uma
colonoscopia uma bió de intestino e tá
lá ele tem um quadro digestivo
relacionado alergia alimentar e saúde
intestinal agora tem pacientes que TM
alergias alimentares que não
tem alteração intestinal a única
manifestação da alergia alimentar é uma
queda de cabelo ou uma alteração na pele
Alé olha só que interessante entendeu
então eu já peguei um monte de paciente
celíaco vea celíaca que é a paciente
alérgico ao glúten né as lectinas e a
única coisa que tinha era a alopécia
padrão androgenética e um pouco de afa e
era celíaco com anticorpo antiendomísio
anticorpo antigliadina
sem nunca ter um quadro intestinal então
o cabelo ele pode ser o marcador de uma
doença celíaca de uma alergia grave sem
a pessoa ter uma manifestação na pele ou
uma manifestação intestinal
sim perfeito é verdade tem muitos
sintomas extraintestinais que estão
relacionados aí o liqu gante o intestino
hiper permeável
sim e levando muitos sintomas aí
inclusive cerebrais tem gente que até
desenvolve a taxia cerebelar por conta
de questões alimentares aí né e é legal
você falar isso por quê Porque o cabelo
a pele né são órgãos
neuroectodérmicas né a mesma origem
embrionária pele cabelo unha esmalte de
dentes e tubo neural é a mesma célula
vem da mesma célula então todas as vezes
que o paciente tá com quadro
dermatológico um quadro capilar se ele
não for bem tratado esse fator que tá
gerando o quadro da pele do cabelo das
unhas dos dentes lá na frente vai
desencadear uma neurotoxicidade um
quadro de alteração neurocomportamental
a gente tem aí se for colocar no pub
médio no Google academic a gente tem 1
milhão
500.000 artigos científicos
correlacionando alterações
neurocomportamentais com sintomas de
pele cabelo e dentes porque é é Mexeu
com um mexeu com todos começa com
manifestação pele cabelo unha dentes lá
na frente Água mole em pedra dura tanto
bate até que fura vai vira
neurotoxicidade Então isso é perfeito
aqui eu agradeço as suas palavras eh
bacanas aí S suas palavras gentis
gratidão eh falando em toxina que que
você acha do Botox isso é muito legal
olha eliz eu adorei sua pergunta tá tem
uma frase além que o pessoal dá risada
mas ela é muito profunda não é a coisa é
o je F coisa coisada e ela é muito
profunda entendeu a toxina botulínica
para você ter ideia foi da primeira
turma de 10 médicos do Brasil a fazer o
primeiro curso de toxina butolínica com
o Dr Jamel Fares que era um médico eh
cirurgião plástico que trouxe pela
cosmedical né tanto o restone quanto o
da Sport
1997 tá Então essa é a toxina botulínica
tipo a que começou a ser estudado em
1890 para numa epidemia de botulismo que
teve por salsichões lá na Alemanha e os
médicos lá vendo que exis tinam
paralisia partic flasa falou olha se a
gente pegar essa substância que a
bactéria dos enlatados do palmito e
diluir eu posso tratar a criança que
nasce PC com paralisia cerebral e fazer
desbloqueio miom muscular e favorecer a
qualidade de vida dessas crianças a elas
fazerem fisioterapia então o primeiro
uso médico da toxina botulínica foi no
começo do século para tratamento
fisioterápico de crianças com paralisia
cerebral espástica
1990 e 1970 os Dres Caru a d Caru os
kutes ela usava para tratamento de
estrabismo Então ela fazia O o aquele
bloqueio no grupo muscular que deixava a
pessoa vesga e como efeito né tinha a
melhora da sug de expressão o marido
dela era dermatologista os pacientes
ficavam na mesma sala de espera viam que
os pacientes do estrabismo melhoraram as
fugas de extração e começaram a usar a
toxina também para uso estético então el
foi começou secundária uso estético na
Alemanha eles usam para terapia neural
para desbloqueio miom muscular então sim
usar uma toxina botulínica tipo a 500
unidades por ml que é só vendida para
médico tá e uso dentro de uma
neuroanatomia de uma fisiologia Onde
você consegue corrigir a musculatura
depressora da facee e equilibrar a
musculatura elevadora da facee que
equilibra o sistema nervoso autônomo do
paciente ajuda num desbloquei uma
terapia niral com uma consequência de
melhora estética perfeitao agora você
pegar uma toxina botulínica tipo b c d e
f g h e j que é o resto do resto do
resto que é vendido para Dent para
esteticista para farmacêutico para não
sei o qu sair aplicando em tudo quanto é
lugar sem estudar tudo isso sem saber
como fazer porque a diluição aplicando
de três em três meses umas doses loucas
hiper diluídas aí sim você vai ter todos
os efeitos colaterais Então essa frase
não é a coisa é o jeito que a coisa é
coisada acho que explica tudo isso né al
acho perfeito né É o jeito que aplica as
coisas né né né esse que é o mais
importante né e o tipo de produto né
você vai pegar uma toxina botulínica
tipo a você vai pagar o frasquinho R
3.000 a tipo B você pagar um frasquinho
de R 300 a R 500 eles diluem para três
pessoas Então não é assim não tem jeito
né não é cara ou é coroa né ou você não
tem jeito né Com saúde não brinca
Ah tem aqui uma pergunta sobre um post
seu acho que você colocou colocou sobre
a relação entre poluição eletromagnética
e soluços né sim sim muito legal porque
assim um dos sintomas que você pode ser
eletr sensível até legal né porque as
pessoas falam assim ah vocêe neg gocio
de poluir S eletromagnética radiação
isso Será que é verdade será que existe
tem um Sid w90 que é cim da
hipersensibilidade eletromagnética Ou
seja você tem 1. 500.000 artigos
científicos e tem Cid é uma coisa que
realmente causa impacto pra saúde não
tem como a as empresas de
telecomunicação negarem isso sendo que
existe um código internacional de
doenças para isso e ela faz o qu ele faz
broncoconstrição vaso constrição ele
estimula o nosso sistema luta e fuga
simpático parassimpático então existem
quatro fases quando você é atacado por
alguma coisa a fase de luta a fase de
fuga a fase de paralisia e a fases e de
exaustão então primeiro você tenta lutar
depois você sai correndo depois você
fica paralisado e depois você f de
mortinho nessas duas primeiras fases
você tem um estímulo do nervo vago
simpático tônico você tá lutando lá o
cortisol lá em cima adrenalina lá em
cima isso pode dar hiperreatividade do
nervo váo você ter um sintoma de soluço
Então como único sintoma de excesso de
polição eletromagnética e radiação aí o
que que você faz para saber se é isso a
terra arranca o sapato pisa na grama e
vai para ambiente externo por quê Porque
a gente tem que ter I uns positivos
entrando pela nosso cucuruco aqui pela
ionosfera e uns negativos entrando pela
superfície da terra se a gente fosse H
da caverna a gente estaria lá
eletricamente estável agora a gente
resolveu colocar um sapato que Sola de
borracha ficar o dia inteiro na frente
do computador recebendo cargas elétricas
a gente vira uma bobina por isso que dá
choque na porta do carro dá choque né
tira a roupa faz cré cré cré cré cré
Então esse excesso de Eletric idade
estática vai bloquear o
eletroencefalograma falar com o
eletrocardiograma falar com os nossos
neurônios falar com as bombas de
membrana com as reações bioquímicas do
nosso corpo causando um curto circuito e
quem que tenta calibrar isso o vago e o
vago às vezes está tanto tentando
reequilibrar as cargas elétricas que
deixa de controlar a essa contratilidade
do nervo frênico né E aí você tem uma
crise de soluços então Pode ser sim
sintoma de poluição
eletromagnética interessante né Essa
correlação sim
eh mas uma pergunta sobre o eflúvio
telógeno como reverter através da
alimentação Adorei Ó te amo prenda por
quê Olha isso nós ocidentais achamos que
fluvio telógeno que é queda de cabelo tá
relacionado a carência lain se eu te
falar que praticamente 100% dos
pacientes que eu tenho pego do dos
últimos anos para cá tem efluvio
telógeno por
hipervitaminose você acredita em mim
hipervitaminose porque as pessoas elas
acham que a gente estudou 30 anos à toa
porque a gente não tem nada o que fazer
na vida entendeu Você gosta de
interpretar exame pedir exame avaliar o
que a pessoa precisa não precisa é tudo
malela as pessoas podem olhar lá na
internet comprar um suplemento lá sair
tomando que não dá nada não é assim que
funciona né D al não vai para nada a
gente estudou 30 anos à toa entendeu né
a gente tem um par de rinho um fígado
que dá tudo que você não usa sai na
urina e tudo bem né não vai causar
alteração renal vai alteração e o que a
gente tem pego hoje D pelo amor eu
peguei ontem uma paciente com complexo B
B12 de
1900 C todo o cabelo dela tá só para
vocês entenderem a gente acha que e
complexo B vai tá lá de 300 800 800 a
1200 legal mas 1800 gente é cumulativo é
neurotóxico vitamina D O pessoal tomando
injetando e porque eu vi magnésio
magnésio que é um monte de coisa excesso
a diferença entre o venel o remédio e a
dose para Celso já falava isso há 500
anos antes de Cristo o excesso de uma
vitamina bloqueia absorção de 100 150
hormônios vitaminas e minerais então
Então hoje o principal fator hoje não tô
brincando com você de efluvio telor de
queda de cabelo excesso de suplementação
é até eu brinco se Deus quisesse que a
gente tomasse tanto suplemento tanto
potinho tanto latinha seria não teria
árvore de comida seria árvore de potinho
Então as pessoas estão deixando de comer
falar vou comer um hambúrguer o dia
inteiro faço cinco vezes por semana my
Tha entendeu eu trabalho o dia inteiro
eu vou comer um hambúrguer mas eu tô no
meu Way desculpa falar o nome meu outro
meu outro meu Shaker e tá tudo certo né
você não precisa de comida entendeu
então assim nada substitui uma
alimentação geneticamente compatível
alimentação viva bem preparada mastigar
bem os alimentos para fazer café da
manhã almoço lanchinho eu trouxe uma
sacolinha lá tão minhas frutas entendeu
a gente tem que ter porque não dá não dá
para você falar que uma uma cápsula Vai
ter o que tem dentro de um alimento aí
Impossível a gente tem alfa beta Gama
Delta tocoferol falando de uma vitamina
você vai falar que uma cápsula de
vitamina E é igual você comer abacate
imagina não tem nada a ver então assim
tudo é alimentação agora tem casos em
que a pessoa tomou tanta coisa comeu
tanta coisa errada que a gente tem que
dosar tudo ver o que tá em excesso que
tá em falta parar de dar o que tá em
excesso e repor o que tá em falta por um
período de tempo e corrigir com a
alimentação geneticamente compatível
então isso aqui não dá para você fazer a
gente estuda 30 anos para isso desculpa
eu tô falando a verdade não dá para
fazer por isso que é nutrologia eu fiz
nutrologia em 2003 fiz em 2009 e 2011 e
começo Pela terceira vez amanhã na
terceira pote de nutrologia porque de
novo de novo de novo de tanto que eu
gosto nutrologia fazer a terceira vez
pela BR nutrologia porque seja o seu
alimento seu medicamento seas pessas
pessoas não pararem de suplementar e
entender que ninguém substitui comida de
verdade elas vão morrer de barriga cheia
perfeito desculpa meu desaba mas que a
gente só tá isso não fica à vontade esse
espaço é seu pode falar o que você
quiser fala um pouquinho sobre a Lope
ariata aqui que a lislei tá perguntando
Nossa adorei também a Lope ariata gente
até uns anos atrás também quando né
aitos décadas de 90 né D lei falava que
a Lope Areta era estress Então os
pacientes chegavam chorando assim falar
Doutor Eu juro que eu não sou estressada
mas todo mundo fala que a alope areada
tá relacionada ao stress é o seguinte o
nosso cabelo ele é uma reserva
metabólica do nosso corpo então conforme
você vai gastando os seus nutrientes né
chega uma hora que o corpo perde a
capacidade de pigmentar aste vai
minguando chega uma hora que o nível de
nutrientes está tão baixo que ele para
de fazer a ase capilar como cada pedaço
do nosso couro cabeludo tá relacionado
um órgão a área da pelada tá relacionada
a exaustão daquele órgão aquele órgão tá
com tanto metal com tanto parasita com
tanta toxina que deixou né tem que fazer
assim ó puxar toda a reserva metabólica
daquele daquela área relacionada
embriologicamente não adianta fazer
injeção de cortisol aliás eu ten uns
artigos científicos mostrando crianças D
com evoluindo para osteopenia
osteoporose por causa de tratamento de
alopécia areata com injeção de
corticoides pensando que o corticoide só
fica aqui e não gera eh eh osteopenia
osteoporose Então assim tá relacionada a
uma disfunção de órgão Então se tá aqui
aqui a ponta do Eber que é a é a é a é a
fumaça mas tem um negócio muito mais
importante uma fadiga uma exaustão de
órgão e sempre tá relacionado com foco
infeccioso subclínico do mesmo lado
então você vai procurar se você tem uma
pelada aqui você desce assim ó
geralmente é um dente quebrado um Nico
alguma coisa do mesmo lado da lesão isso
com alopecia areat com úlcera com ferida
de perna atrás de uma ferida de perna
tem um subclínico também porque tem um
dermátomo e você não trata ferida de
pele sem avaliar o órgão correspondente
e o dente relacionado com isso então
nosso corpo é tudo fofoqueiro a gente
não é esquartejado infelizmente né t a
gente dentro da integrativa fala fala
fala isso mas não dá para pegar um
pedaço do corpo cuidar e jogar no
aquário todo sujo não dá
infelizmente tem uma pessoa interessada
em passar com você aí que que que você
diz para ela Então na verdade assim a
gente brinca viu alaim que a gente tem
um um perfil de paciente para ser
atendido aqui então Eh paciente que tá
Aim
deic passando coisa na cabeça injetando
coisa não quer mudar estilo de vida não
tá a fim de mudar alimentação não tá a
fim de realmente entender que o corpo
ele tá gritando através do cabelo eu
peço que nem Marco consulta comigo
entendeu por quê Porque para mim não
funciona esse negócio PVA Bela viola por
dentro pomo lorento então assim a gente
tem que tratar de dentro para fora e o
cabelo tem que ser uma consequência de
uma saúde metabólica com perpetuidade
então eu gosto de um tratamento começo
meio e fim hoje eu atendo pacientes
encaminhados pelos alunos que fizeram o
nosso curso de imersão são quase 900
alunos então eles vêm já avaliando essa
parte do terreno biológico lógico tudo e
eu já faço essa parte médica hormonal em
pacientes que já t esse perfil que
entendem que o cabelo é reflexo de um
estilo de vida que não tá correspondendo
com a sua genética então assim se você é
uma pessoa que realmente só quer que o
cabelo cresça e tá nem aí se você é
saudável ou não não marque consulta
comigo tá agora se você quer realmente
tratar o seu cabelo entendendo que o seu
corpo tá gritando e vai melhorar de Dede
para fora aí tudo bem aí você é
bem-vindo mas você faz atendimento
online ou só presencial faço online
também a gente usa pacientes mandam as
amostras do cabelo na minese tudo a
gente faz online também mas tem que tá
no perfil de entender que o corpo é como
um todo sem
dúvida tá perguntando sobre um detox de
pineal Tá além de evitar o Flu e cloro
que podemos fazer Então na verdade não
existe um detox de de pineal né a gente
fala que adrenal é o nosso órgão que faz
a interface entre um ambiente estressor
quando o nosso ambiente tá com uma
quantidade de toxinas maior do que a
nossa capacidade de excreção é o fluxo
de entrada de toxinas água agrotóxicos
pesticidas conservantes corantes tá
maior do que as nossas adrenais consegue
mandar o fígado Rio intestino pulmão
pele mandar a gente entra em exaustão ou
estress ou fadiga de adrenal ap pineal
normalmente você tem fatores neuro
estressores não é só um detox de pineal
geralmente a pessoa que tem fadiga de
pineal ela tá vivendo num ambiente neur
estressor maior do que ela pode suportar
Eu por exemplo fui médica militar 5 anos
foi quando eu tive uma fadiga de Pinel
um bô para mim era muito para aquilo que
a minha genética podia eh suportar
entendeu então eu tomei uma opção ou eu
vivo Tenho saúde e mudo de cargo peço
baixa de uma vaga única vaga Estado de
São Paulo pública ou eu vou ficar doente
pro resto da vida então não é só isso
mas eu tem quer acertar água alimento
estilo de vida abdicar de coisas às
vezes para ter qualidade então nessa
época eu era tava com os dois filhos
pequenos tava fazendo duas
pós-graduações reformando minha casa
entendeu assim não dá para você querer
ser super mãe super médica super e ter
saúde de pineal você pode fazer tudo
isso só que uma coisa de cada vez Então
tem que haver uma gestão de terreno
biológico alimentação de guerra Banco de
Horas de Sono está num ambiente calmo
tranquilo não querer abraçar o mundo né
fazer 500.000 coisas de uma vez a mulher
tem a tendência disso ela a mulher saiu
pro mercado de trabalho mas ela continua
sendo mãe sendo esposa sendo né dona de
casa ninguém vai tirar isso dela ter
cuidado do marido ter cuidado dos filhos
ter cuidado da casa o homem é um
ajudador mas a responsabilidade é dela
então a gente tem que fazer escolhas
para poder fazer a gestão E se a gente
não faz isso o neuro emocional
neuroendócrino imunológico gasta nossos
hormônios consome nossa imunidade e a
gente não fica bem se a gente não tá bem
o marido não fica bem os filhos não tá
bem a profissão fica bem então é o
momento de para tudo e priorizar e
comece a olhar para você mesmo para si
mesmo do que olhar pros outros não tem
como fazer detox cápsula mágica não
existe Quantos minutos a mais nós temos
eh dentro dos seus compromissos aí Tô
tranquila tô só a
dispensação obrigado é tem uma pergunta
aqui sobre cabelo
estrogênio isso é bem legal gente eu tô
adorando essa pergunta de vocês ó tá tá
10 hein pessoal o público éa Aí meu Deus
hein selecionado o pessoal só falta um
CRM todo mundo das galáxias parabéns viu
né olha só hoje um grande problema é um
que a gente tem na Humanidade para
predominância estrogênica entendeu Então
imagina assim se eu pego o globo
terrestre do Equador para cima eu tenho
uma população mundial mais
progestogênios como que eu sei que a
mulher é
progestogênico campia de natação nada de
frente nada de costas ela é
progestogênico Equador para baixo a
gente tem as mulheres estrogênicas que
tem uma necessidade maior de estrógeno
Então como que eu sei que ela é
estrogênica geralmente é a mulata né Tem
um maior volume de mamas de glúteos né
então ela precisa ter contato com
substâncias estrogênicas Quais são as
principais fontes de estrógenos grãos
Quais são as principais fontes de
progestágenos Raízes Que que aconteceu
os os progestogênico europeus vieram
morar onde na América do Sul e comer
grão arroz feijão comer fora isso
muitos eh substâncias de petróleo
pesticidas agrotóxicos funcionam como
disruptores o corpo lê como se fosse
estrógeno E aí o estrógeno ele fica
proporcionalmente receptor estrogênico
maior do que o de progesterona o que que
isso causa a Quim queda de cabelo
rarefação capilar aumento de gordura no
fí fid cin medi vários policísticos e
hiperplasia prostática benigna a
rarefação capilar alopécia padrão
androgenética masculino feminino isso
tanto no homem quanto na mulher Então a
gente tem que analisar a individualidade
da pessoa se a pessoa mais
progestogênios e a pessoa mais
estrogênica equilibrar a ingesta de
grãos e eliminar os disruptores
endócrinos né então não é repor por isso
que eu brinco tem uma outra musiquinha
que eu falo antes de repor precisa
remover precisa limpar aquilo que tá
entupindo o receptor hormonal para que
às vezes os próprios hormônios vitaminas
minerais que já estão presentes no corpo
vem o corpo consiga aproveitar o maior
problema hoje da população mundial é que
as pessoas estão morrendo de barriga
cheia tem uma quantidade gigante de
toxinas pesticidas agrot que comp
com os hormônios vitaminas minerais aí
eu falo paraos meus pacientes você colhe
o exame de sangue tá cheio de coisa você
vai ver a nível de célula Tá tudo com
carência porque nada nada nada e morre
na praia fica passeando na corrente
sanguínea e a célula toda entupida não
consegue ler nada por isso que a gente
não usa só exame de sangue hoje para
avaliar hormônios vitaminas Minera a
gente negócio já mudou há muito tempo
tem um monte de coisa que a gente usa
agora perfeito Ah que já foi é o de cima
que eu queria mostrar o que que você
acha do uso de Minoxidil ácido
hialurônico adorei gente vocês estão
maravilhosos tá tudo pergunta polêmica
que eu tava assim por favor alguém me
pergunte tá na maioria da área capilar
muitos tratamentos foram coisas que eram
usadas para outras coisas e observar o
que efeito colateral a crescer cabelo tá
o próprio né bloqueador de aromatase de
cin Alf redutase né a finasterida a
dutasterida era um tratamento para
hiperplasia prostática para diminuir
próstata de homens com próstatas
hiperplásicas E aí para esses pacientes
começavam a crescer cabelo Eles
resolveram dar esse remédio para quem
não tem próstata grande entendeu para
crescer cabelo aí aconteceu todos os
problemas que a gente sabe dos efeitos
colaterais tá então assim não é a coisa
o jeito que a coisa coisada Minoxidil
mesma coisa era uma medicação
antihipertensiva para tratar hipertensão
ele vai atuar na artéria renal imagina
dout Laí ele é urologista Gente pelo
amor El vai bloquear sistema renina
angiotensina aldosterona vai mexer com
bombas de sódio e potássio quase não tem
interferência na saúde cardíaca na saúde
vascular na microcirculação e as pessoas
ficam usando usando isso para crescer
cabelo entendeu que eu tô falando então
é matar uma baratinha usando uma bomba
atômica a gente tem tanta coisa que
estimula bombas também sem causar né eu
falo todo fetiço tem um preço você quer
saber o o fetiço o preço de um feitiço
que é um medicamento Olha a bula É só
ler a bula compensa para você ter cabelo
você usar uma droga quer utilizar para
baixar a pressão se você já tem pressão
baixa que que vai acontecer com a sua
pressão né você tem a pressão normal o
que que vai acontecer com a sua pressão
Ah mas só pega no cabelo tá o nosso
corpo não tem
absorção a superfície de absorção do
tubo digestório é 12 m qu a nossa pele é
32 M qu coro cabeludo e fio de cabelo a
lá em 100 m qu pulmão 1000 M qu quando
você tá usando uma substância no seu
cabelo tá tomando no banho você tem
132 M qu de superfície de absorção já
peguei paciente que teve síncope baixou
a pressão usando esse tipo de medicação
tá ácido hialurônico mesma coisa não é a
coisa o jeito que a coisa é coisado
existe a b c d e f g h i j k l m z de
qualidade de produto não tem como você
querer pagar baratinho uma coisa boa
então assim o grande problema é a
técnica de aplicação quem aplica a
qualidade do produto plano de aplicação
e o terreno biológico paciente tá bom
naquele momento ele tá inflamado ele tá
com infecção Tá com inflamação você vai
jogar uma coisa diferente no corpo não
vai ser a última gota que faz o copo
transbordar Então é isso que a gente vê
eu comecei trabalhar com isso com toxina
com ácido hialurônico ala em
1997 não tinha nada disso por quê Porque
era um produto só era feito por médico
dermatologista que tinha que fazer 4
anos de especialização para poder fazer
esse tipo de aplicação hoje infelizmente
tem 500 produtos muitos da China não tô
falando nada mal contra ninguém mas não
dá para ser caro barato isso é a mesma
coisa e um monte de gente sem informação
nenhuma aplicando sem avaliar o terreno
biológico então Quando aplica vai no
profissional não médico quando começa a
dar problema quem que vai procurar D Laí
para resolver o problema o médico
dermatologista Legista é assim ó de
necrose de efeito colateral porque fez
uma aplicação baratinha com outro
profissional então o grande problema é
isso não é a coisa o jeito que a coisa é
coisada É
automedicação sim é uma pergunta curiosa
aqui
né isso a a medicina ambiental né ou
neob biologia né que a gente aqui no
Brasil é um negócio meio que obscuro mas
na Europa por conta da Guerra das Bombas
né de todo o problema ambiental que eles
tiveram pós primeira segunda guerra
mundial nagasa Hiroshima fux Caua
Chernobil tem uma tem áreas ainda
contaminadas por sesio 125 por radiação
então lá por legislação há 70 anos antes
de construir qualquer casa qualquer
edificação a a prefeitura local Exige
uma avaliação do subsolo né para ver se
não tem veio d'água para ver se não tem
passa fiação para ver se não tem fenda
tectônica para você se não é um local
contaminado isso chama
geobiologia aqui no Brasil eu acredito
que vai demorar sei lá quantos anos 1000
anos para isso acontecer mas existem sim
casas que curam casas que matam tem eh
ambientes com domínios que foram
construídos em aterro sanitário Então
vou contar uma história Era Uma Vez há
20 anos atrás quando tinha se campanha
na televisão que fala assim gente não
joga pile e bateria no lixo tá todo
mundo vai lá e coloca naquela caixinha
amarela que fica nos pontos específicos
aí todo mundo obedeceu né ninguém chou
pilha no lixo aí foi tudo para ter
sanitária que que acontece pilha com
bateria tem urânio com rádio e vira um
gás chamado radônio que é um gás que não
tem cheiro que não tem cor que ele é
leve que ele entra pelo subsolo da casa
e a principal causa de Câncer em
paciente por exemplo câncer de pulmão em
paciente Que Nunca fumou câncer de mama
em paciente que não deveria ter câncer
de Mamba Câncer de cérebro em gente sem
genética para Câncer de cérebro entendeu
então lá na Europa nos Estados Unidos
estão construindo casas antre radônio já
então tem uma uma uma área que capta
esse gás e joga pra estratosfera Então
existe isso existe eh se fala disso
atualmente infelizmente não aqui em
Campinas tem condomínios de luxo
construídos em cima de locais que foram
aterro sanitário e a quantidade de
pacientes ela em com esclerose múltipla
demência Parkinson câncer nesses
condomínios é gigante Fora as antenas né
de 4G 5g passando então radiação de
baixo e radiação de cima então é uma
coisa que eles estudam lá há 70 anos faz
parte do código de obras da engenharia
civil na Europa e no Japão há 70 anos
aqui não sei quanto tempo que vai
demorar para isso ser aprovado acho meio
difícil né perfeito Tem tem uma pergunta
aqui sobre queda de cabelos relacionado
aquela doença de 3 anos atrás sim eu
prefo eu vou pedir para por favor para
não fal o nome isso então deixa contar S
só falar o é o que que você sugere pra
queda de cabelo relacionado aquele
bichinho lá isso deixa eu contar na
minha prática não sei se você também Alé
Mas na minha prática eu eu eu separo
medicina pré-pandemia pós-pandemia tá eu
sou não fala mais essa
palavra tudo diferente tudo diferente
mudou tudo mudou tudo mudou tudo a gente
não sabe tá então hoje é tudo diferente
a gente não sabe é tudo novo não sabe o
que foi feito como foi feito como é
feito minha mãe pergunta o que que você
acha Eu não sei porque é tudo novo a
gente nunca estudou isso agora tão
acontecendo várias coisas relacionadas
com isso manifestações de queda de
cabelo alergias de pele alterações de
unhas inclusive nessa aula nesse próximo
curso que eu vou dar eh de para para
profissionais da área da saúde vai ser
uma atualização só disso falando dos
sintomas que a gente pode identificar
através de queda de cabelo alterações da
pele alterações das unhas que são os
únicos sinais que eu consigo ter para
identificar essas possíveis
contaminações incubadas subclínicas
antes do paciente às vezes desenvolver
um quadro né sistêmico algum carro eh
algum quadro que gera uma lesão em algum
órgão então é muito bacana você utilizar
nessa época né de 2019 até 2023 a gente
fazia muito diagnóstico paciente mandava
foto da língua da língua da unha do
cabelo eu falava Ixe vai ter que lá
corre para hospital porque eu sei que
você tá entendeu porque a pele é um dos
primeiros a falar pra gente então mancha
roxa na língua pits nas unhas alteração
na arte capilar é um dos primeiros
sintomas aí que a gente consegue às
vezes identificar precocemente antes de
ter alteração no exame de sangue e
alteração no órgão mais Vital então ó
nota 10 aí Maravilha eh aqui tá
perguntando também sobre os implantes né
é um assunto que eu falei há 4 anos
atrás tomei uma salap
da sociedade de plásticos né entraram
com uma uma
eh entraram com uma um papel lá no
conselho para para não falar mais do
assunto Entendeu Tá e agora agora agora
agora agora ficou famoso esse assunto né
Na época eu falei eu era o único que
falava agora tá todo mundo falando esse
assunto aí você tem algo a dizer sobre
isso aí não eu tá gente caso Ferreiro
Espeto de pau tá então pela primeira vez
publicamente eu tô falando disso que
aconteceu comigo o ano passado tá eu
tive
uma ruptura de prótese em março do ano
passado no dia do meu aniversário tive
um um acidente Zinho bobo né bati aqui a
costela e teve uma microfissura na
prótese e eu quase morri até eu consegui
detectar o que que era né então
infecções de repetição alergias de
repetição as minhas vitaminas todas
loucas meus hormônios todos loucos eu
fiz exame de ultrassom de mambas estava
normal ressonância nuclear magnética
normal não apareceu na ressonância nem
no ultrassom tá e eu sentindo sentindo
que tinha alguma coisa que não tava bem
aí fui numa colega querida Dra Luci care
que me examinou me investigou falou tem
alguma coisa aí pode tirar e eu tirei a
prótese em 14 de agosto do ano passado e
demorei 6 meses para me recuperar tá
então assim se você não tá se sentindo
bem se você tá sentindo que sua alma sai
do corpo e volta de vez em quando se
você começa a ter alteração bagunça nos
seus hormônios se suas vitaminas ficam
diferentes sua pele fente o cabelo fica
diferente olha eu usei o melhor melhor
prótese a Larinha tava todo ano fazendo
tudo certinho fazendo monitoramento não
apareceu em nenhum exame tá então é
muito sério não espera o negócio ficar
apocalíptico para você investigar isso
mesmo tendo estilo de vida super
saudável me controlando super saudável é
muito sério isso o problema é quando
junta pró mama pró glúteo faceta
preenchimento toxina implante a pessoa
vira humanoide não vira mais um humano
né então é sério esse assunto realmente
eu quase morri o ano passado por causa
disso realmente eu acho que só não morri
porque eu né Tem alguma coisa tem alguma
coisa eu fui atrás que se eu dependesse
dos exames convencionais eu
provavelmente não tava aqui para contar
a história é muito sério isso tudo ho
tem alguns cirurgiões plásticos muito
conscientes Inclusive tem um perfil no
Instagram só fala desse assunto mas
quando eu falei desse assunto me
silenciar Ainda bem que esse assunto não
foi silenciado e ele está cada vez mais
eh sendo divulgado as pessoas estão se
conscientizando sobre
isso uma pergunta sobre tratamento da
toxoplasmose Nossa que pergunta
maravilhosa gente acabei de conversar
isso com a paciente querida existe uma
uma né mesma coisa né um um preceito e
um
conceito diferente da Saúde ocidental da
oriental imagina que o nosso corpo tem
10 AAS células para 10 a 12 bactérias
nós somos formados por mais bactérias do
que células essas bactérias são Flora
Elas moram no nosso corpo a flora
vaginal a flora intestinal a flora bucal
a flora anal Flora tá o mundo foi criado
para Nós seres humanos e pros bichos era
pros bichos est fora do nosso corpo e a
nossa Flora tá dentro do corpo a flora é
flora quando ela tá na quantidade certa
no local certo quando a gente come
errado tem hábitos de vida alterado tá
tot como começa a trazer toxinas do
ambiente externo pro nosso ambiente
interno os bichos de Fora começam a
achar que tem um direito de vir borar
aonde tem a comida deles e começam a se
proliferar então hoje tá uma loucura de
protocolo de desira
despas achando que a culpa é dos Vermes
é das bactérias a dos vírus sendo que o
problema enquanto a gente não mudar o
nosso terreno biológico a gente vai
continuar virando depositório de vírus
bactérias fungos e parasitos até aquela
cérebro frase nós somos um aquário e o o
peixinho tá com fungo aí você tira o
peixe trata ele e coloca no aquário todo
sujo então a pessoa fica fazendo carn
Casas Bahias vermífugo antiviral
antiparasitário até eu brinco né acho
que a gente podia criar um protocolo né
pra gente ficar rico segunda-feira você
Tom antibiótico terça-feira
antifungico quarta-feira vermífugo
quinta-feira né é um antiparasitário e
sexta-feira um quimioterápico pronto
olha que para ver você não vai ter mais
vírus bactérias fungos parasitas nem nem
nada disso não é isso é estilo de vida é
você se alimentar direito fazer
atividade física tomar sol viver no
ambiente neurocomportamental que você tá
podendo suportar naquele momento a gente
nunca vai vai conseguir modificar o
nosso bioma através de remédio remédio é
um fetiço onde que tem o preço do fetiço
na bula é só você ler a bula então para
você controlar e tratar a Toxoplasma se
a pessoa tem um gato mora no meio de um
gato Tem um monte de gato que vai
namorar na rua cada fezes de gato
contamina o ambiente por 180 Dias gente
como que vai fazer você entende vai
ficar tomando
vida então eu tive vários pacientes com
diagnóstico de autismo diagnóstico de
alopecias que é impossível você curar no
ambiente que te adoeceu MSE não tô
falando PR gente matar os gatos mas tem
gato de raça e tem gato que é gato de
rua Então gato tem que tá na rua
cachorro tem que tá no chão passarinho
tem que tá na árvore e ser humano na
cama PR que coloca gato na cama ou no
berço junto com bebê coloca cachorro
para lamber o prato o passarinho para
higienizar os dentes e o que é flora
para nós é patogênico para eles O que é
patogênico para eles é flora para nós
bicho é bicho gente é gente gente gato
se lambe né el deita no sofá coloca lá
deita onde você dorme e você não
consegue se
recontamination amo eu tenho meus
cachorros sabe eu amo tudo só que cada
um no seu quadrado cada um coloca né
então eu assim dentro da filogenética da
zoologia né a gente tem que respeitar o
ambiente de cada um Toda vez que você
muda uma fisiologia você cria uma
patologia simples assim perfeito
polm Oi tô sendo polêmica aqui mas é um
po acaba aí por enquanto não apareceu
nenhum Hater aqui não ah então tá bom só
pessoas agradecendo pelo seu
conhecimento aí tão extenso que Ana
Paula perguntando sobre implantes
dentários Eu sei que você tem um
conhecimento bom disso até pelo teu
trabalho bonito que você faz com o Dr
Rodrigo vin né sim sim então mesma coisa
gente não é a coisa do jeito que a coisa
coisada essa frase gente é muito
profundo entende porque
existe vários tipos de implantes vários
materiais várias Colinas né Se a gente
for olhar quantos produtos né o dentista
e o ortopedista trabalha tem os três
principais profissionais hoje que mais
colocam o material não self no corpo do
paciente né o dentista o Ortopedista e o
cirurgião plástico são os três que mais
colocam substâncias que não são eh eh
substâncias orgânicas no corpo da pessoa
e a gente tem que testar se avaliar o
quanto que a pessoa tá de substâncias
orgânicas no corpo e quanto que ela tá
de toxinas então por exemplo Às vezes a
pessoa já tá mascando o chiclete tem uma
marca de chiclete que é dióxido de
titânio aí tá passando filtro solar
filtro químico que é dióxido de titânio
aí já tá com cinco implantes de titânio
na boca e coloca mais 10 entendeu aí vai
dar reação alérgica ao implante porque o
problema é o o implante ou o chiclete o
protetor o a a a dose que tá levando a
isso então antes de arrancar os
implantes vamos avaliar os outros
fatores ambientais que colaboram paraa
contaminação do corpo quanto aquele
metal aí se não tiver jeito aí tudo bem
você vai trocar mas você vai tratando o
paciente com uma cebola né você vai
tratando de fora para dentro e aí você
vai removendo o que faz dar Aler alergia
no corpo é a quantidade de toxinas
cumulativas como que a gente trata a
alergia sabê eu tô nessa área da alergia
desde
1997 antigamente a gente tava
antialérgico hoje a gente entende que a
alergia ela é o quanto que o copo tá
para transbordar você escolhe a você
detecta qual que é a substância
alergênica e você mantém na mínima dose
que o corpo consegue fazer gestão sem
estimular a resposta imunológica a
resposta inflamatória e vai ensinando o
o paciente a detectar essa principal
carga tóxica a se blindar dela e manter
esses níveis sempre baixos Então quem é
alérgico sempre vai ser se eu pro resto
da vida for mexer com cloro comer uma
bacia de arroz tiver contato com lectina
eu volto a ter convulsão e volto a ter
alergia agora ten que manter os cuidados
com a minha água a minha aguinha que ela
eu pego um saquinho de chá coloco na
minha aguinha né eu vou tomar uma xícara
de café eu sempre coloco um saquinho de
chá PR ajudar a limpar o cloro evito de
comer grãos pro resto da minha vida para
manter minha carga tóxica de arsênico e
cloro baixa PR pai que eu vou num num
clube e lavaram os banheiros com cloro
aquilo lá não me dá um choque
anafilático então é gestão gestão
ambiental estilo de vida para você ter
realmente uma qualidade de vida uma
saúde bem-estar Só que detectar o que
para você é alergênico aquilo que para
você é os 80% da sua
saúde estudante de nutrição pode fazer o
seu
curso por enquanto a gente tem esse
último curso de imersão que vai ser 6 7
8 de Março é a última turma que eu só
mantive além porque eu sou de Honrar
minha palavra Então teve gente que se
inscreveu ano passado não pode fazer
então mantive essa turma para honrar
meus compromissos mas eu tô terminando
encerrando esse ciclo do curso a gente
vai entrar com as mentorias só para
médicos realmente né E aí a gente até tá
conversando das nossas mentorias aí que
é realmente pegar na mão desses
profissionais e ensinar realmente essa
filosofia eu acho que integrativo é uma
filosofia né de entender olar o paciente
como um todo e a gente não consegue
mudar a cabeça do profissional em TRS
dias então essa esse movimento da
mentoria que é o próximo ciclo aí que a
gente vai lançar vai ser depois a gente
vai focar principalmente pro público
médico eh E olha que legal além vai ter
certificação europeia tá essa legal vou
passar tudo você vai ver o Dr Alin vai
est participando vocês vão ver que legal
certificação europeia também então é uma
coisa bem bacana mas o timinho do Timão
Quem fez o curso quem não fez acabou
quem quiser fazer tem que correr que tem
medo de vaga só depois ó eu vou virar
estrelinha né vou só
fazer Tá certo tem uma pergunta aqui
sobre lupos e doença autoimune n qu
falar algo para Ana Paula aí para dar o
suporte para ela eu tive lupos né fui
diagnosticada lupos fui medicada dentro
da convencional 15 anos né e falaram que
ela genética não tem cura ia morrer
amanhã né que não ia ter jeito e através
da detecção do que tá fazendo mal do que
tava fazendo mal para mim que no meu
caso era o arroz a água quem vai falar
né que uma toxina aí intracelular Pode
ser lá o arsênico que é hidrossolúvel a
o cloro da água que fazia esses
complexos organometálicos e dava Fan
Positivo né o célula L positivo atraía
Toxoplasma então você vê que hoje hoje a
gente entende que há 20 anos atrás você
não tinha microscopia eletrônica para
saber o que que era aquele padrão
pontilhado achava que era uma coisa
genética autoimune Hoje a gente vai
detectar que são pedacinhos né restos de
bactérias restos de metais que o sistema
imunológico vai comter tem um porquê e
um como se você conseguir descobrir o
sistema imunológico ele tem que ser
modulado não adianta você ficar
bloqueando ele você tem que identificar
Por que que ele tá hiperestimulado
estilo de vida alimentação hábitos de
vida e aí você dessensibilizar através
de mudanças de estilo de vida é de novo
é impossível você eh eh mudar adequar
uma fisiologia com remédio remédio ele
vai né é um calaboca você segura aquele
aquele pininho da panela de pressão com
fogo ligado tem um preço tá bua lá agora
mudanças de estilo de vida mudanças de
hábito de vida requer um comprometimento
do paciente tem paciente tem que estar
disposto a parar de fazer o que tava
fazendo primeira coisa que paciente né é
impossível você curar ter um resultado
diferente Mantendo as mesmas coisas que
você faz então você tá disposto a mudar
Ah não tô aí então você não é o meu
perfil de paciente tá disposto não posso
fazer se quiser mudar de Cid de país
mudar tô disposto pronto então esse é o
perfil de paciente da integrativ você
tem que est disposto a mudar porque
senão não consegue ter resultados
diferentes fazendo as mesmas coisas que
fazia antes não tem Milagre né
D Com certeza bem pessoal nós vamos já
preparar para encerrar até pra gente
deixar a doutora descansar também a
gente poder cumprir nossas obrigações aí
do Lar né is família e deixa eu
selecionar uma pergunta que eu pulei
aqui só avisando o Wilson que ela Ela
demonstrou assim um pouquinho doing test
mais cedo tá volta o vídeo que ela fez
uma demonstração aqui viu ao vivo do
oing isso tem uma outra pergunta aqui
deixa eu
localizar aqui essa aqui ó tem 65 anos a
partir do 57 Tornei me alerg com iní
elevada cada de insetos isso é muito
legal é possível reverter essa
fragilidade parabéns para democratizar
essas informações gratidão no assim ó
alergia poeira
ácaro picada de inseto chocolate ovo
sempre é secundária Imagina assim você
tem eu gosto de mostrar o meu o meu
complexo organom metálico al Olha que
legal aqui ó é um uma uma substância
alergênica tá vendo ela é formada por
cabadas tem cabadas tá então você tem
várias substâncias sendo que vão sendo
aderidas a um fator causal primário Esse
é o fator causal primário e aí ele vai
se acumulando no seu corpo toda a toxina
é uma carga elétrica positiva é um
Radical Livre Então chega uma hora que
ela se torna magneticamente ativa e
começa a atrair restos de célula
microplástico pesticida e vai gerando
aqui uma gororoba a gente fala que é uma
gororoba entendeu que são as respostas
alérgicas secundárias terciárias
quaternárias eu mesma quando era criança
eu tenho bucs de testes alérgicos o
paciente começa com uma substância
alergênica vai repetir daqui seis meses
tem quatro vai repetir daqui seis meses
tem oito eu trabalhei de 97 a 2005 no
ambulatório de alergia lá da Santa Casa
de São Paulo a gente ajudou a fabricar
as baterias padrão Standard o pit Test e
o pet test que é usado no perfil
brasileiro a gente só tinha bateria
americana para usar na época a gente
ajudou como como como residente a fazer
levantamento bibliográfico para ver
quais eram os principais alergênicos do
Brasil e a gente via que era uma reação
em cadeia tinha uma substância mãe lá
que inflamava o o corpo do paciente
tornava sensível ao segundo ao terceiro
ao quarto ao quinto ao sexto ele fala
como se fosse uma cebola por isso que
muita gente hoje tem alergia
incompatibilidade ao glúten e ao leite e
às vezes não é primário Às vezes o
primário é uma outra coisa é o brócolis
é arroz é o tomate que inflamou o
intestino deixou o intestino permeável E
aí a lactasa que fica lá né nas
velocidades intestinais e a e a e a
zonulina e a ocludina que estão lá na
crista do enteró começa a ficar careca e
a pessoa se torna incompatível
intolerante ao glúten e a lactose
secundária mas a causa não é realmente a
picada de inseto ác uma poeira o negócio
é mais embaixo então você vê no meu caso
era o arroz e o cororo da água e eu
tinha alergia a chocolate a gema de ovo
a poro a ácaro a pela de gato que na
verdade era
hipersensibilidade secundária minha o
que eu falo é como se tivesse tomado uma
queimadura de sol e aí você vai passar
qualquer creme qualquer hidratante vai
te dar alergia Então são as alergias
secundárias você tem que dessensibilizar
até achar o alergeno primário esse que é
o foco demora um pouquinho mas a gente
sempre
consegue maravilha Muito bom então então
pessoal vamos encerrar essa Live porque
ela já está chegando a 1 hora3 a gente
pode chamar
novamente em outras ocasiões para
continuar explanando aí continuar nos
brindando com seu conhecimento Tão
Profundo aí sobre vários temas e eu
queria agradecer imensamente a a sua
participação o seu aceite do
convite muito feliz aí por ter aceitado
e por termos tido essa Live tão
enriquecedora com perguntas aí tão
pertinentes a Eu que agradeço tô muito
contente al acho que é gostoso quando a
gente tá com colega da área que tá na
mesma frequência né tá no mesmo
pensamento Então a gente tem essa
liberdade né que você continue com o seu
trabalho maravilhoso sou sua fã meu
filho também né os dois n est o Bruno tá
no terceiro ano ele falou ass fal eu
consigo me atualizar dentro da da área
integrativa pelos vídeos do Dr alí Então
continue seu trabalho né mesmo grandes
pessoas são combatidas são questionadas
mas não desista que seu trabalho tá
impactando a vida de Muitas pessoas não
com certeza desistir eu não vou não de
vez em quando desanima porque Tom umas
trolada umas cetada aí mas a gente
levanta e e continua Então pessoal que
tá assistindo muito obrigado pela sua
participação pelas perguntas
maravilhosas aí e vocês são maravilhosos
um beijo no coração de vocês e a gente
se vê aí na próxima Live Tchau pessoal
Tchau gente
gratidão